but is it the metaverse is next
metaverse is is intriguing uh i hate i
mean i i'm not gonna go to um facebook's
metaphors but there's meta verses and
it's kind of like what they call it
second world
back when people could build their own
properties and sell them for real cash
and all that and it'll happen but i love
um the idea
of the of the real geeks the solid geeks
that just want to live 24 7 inside their
goggles and deal with people that way i
mean ready player one
ready player one that's what happens
scott says this to me every single day
he's like i don't get it i'm like ready
player one it's not for everybody maybe
but it's for deep geeks that i was i
feel like oh go ahead are there gonna be
music festivals
in the metaverse
yes there are let me give you an example
um for virtual reality
you know again that is just oh my god so
amazing it's like you are there emotions
tell you what products will succeed but
then i saw a live basketball game live
you know and you players go run in front
of you and you'd be turning your head i
saw a football game that way and you'd
be under the basket and they dunk it
right downtown oh the emotions and then
i saw a coldplay at a at a concert in
chicago on vr my gosh and the camera's
moving right around on the stage you're
you're seeing so much more than just a
concert that i'm for that yeah and i
think concerts will be
real real plentiful in um
in a metaversal here's a problem with
the metaverse bandwidth
how can we do it
you can put on goggles and be in an
artificial reality and it looks really
good high resolution
but a high resolution camera is kind of
narrow neural focus you'd have to take
10 of those around your head and then
you have to take 10 of them this way
that's a hundred times the resolution
just to get the resolution you want okay
um so maybe only do a hemisphere 50
times we need a lot of resolution to
make it look like it's a real world able
to change that fast like it's real i've
you know done i've done a few demos like
that and it's very impressive so moore's
law does have a little ways to go
maybe it's still we're still finding
tricks like instead of building
transistors horizontally across this way
we're building them vertically and yeah
little tricks that pack them in tighter
yeah i have a question about like
looking towards the future with
technology because like to me with the
metaverse it's fascinating it's exciting
but it's sort of an extension of
what we're already doing a little bit vr
has existed it's kind of like it's video
games it's entertainment
but to me like do you have an opinion
about like the neural link or things
like this where like our brains would be
connected
like through some
technology
like elon musk talks about it and stuff
i haven't heard anything that's going to
be important to people
any of that kind of stuff neural links
and and think certain thoughts and steer
steer a car kind of so slow it can't
really work into real life i i haven't
bought into any of that um in the fut
everything that bothers me these days
i'm very negative pessimistic about
technology because so many things
that i think i have i don't own anymore
and they change they change so
drastically i can't even operate them
our tesla out there is a good example
and then oh it would i'd have a
different way to it they changed the way
to it by voice if the voice button on
the steering wheel worked but i've been
waiting two months for service no i just
hate everything's called artificial
intelligence it's artificial all right
but it's not intelligence like a brain
it's just figuring out a few little
formulas okay if you usually go um buy
some milk on wednesday it's wednesday
we'll notify you to go buy some milk uh
so many times when it's not what you
want to do that wednesday you're in a
different city you know they're just
they're just interruptions in your life
just like spam
and i really and a lot of the old school
ways i stick with old school email i
don't do the the social web and
um
maybe it's because that's where i
started
america if you thought jackass forever
was crazy oh boy do i have a show for
you it's a multimedia comedy show called
the bucket list tour and the stuff i
filmed for this show is way too hot for
jackass like the general anesthesia bike
ride the vasectomy olympics and sky
jacking the footage is so intense we
have full grown men passing out at
almost every city this bus goes to
so if you think you can handle it get
your tickets right now at stevo.com
[Applause]